[Music]
crystal's in cleveland ohio hi crystal
how are you
[Music]
hi dave good how are you better than we
deserve what's up
so my husband and i um last year we were
making nearly six figures
blowing through our debt doing great
and my two-year-old well he was one at
the time a one-year-old son
unexpectedly started having
seizures so
it was a long process we're still
struggling we have
lots of doctor's appointments all the
time but how's he doing he made the
decision
he's doing better much better did the
diagnosis coming down
they diagnosed it he had something
called gray matter heterotopia um they
found a spot in his brain that shouldn't
be there basically so
it's been emotional yeah
i guess we made the decision for
just my own emotional
state
i was a school teacher and we made the
decision for me to stay home
so that's understandable we
yeah we basically cut our income in half
but our expenses
were the same so we blew through our
emergency fund and
pretty much all of the debt that we had
paid off accrued again
um
so we're looking at where we're
gazelle's
mindset but we don't know what our next
step should be
so we have a few reasons
have you adjusted your lifestyle now to
be within his income or are you still
going in the hole
we're
we've adjusted all the extra stuff out
but just our mortgage um so you have to
sell your house in order to stay home
and be with your child
yes when's it going up for sale
should have gone up for sale the first
day you came home from school
absolutely my husband doesn't want to
sell i don't care so
i don't care what your husband wants
you guys you guys already made this
choice you made the right choice we're
going to stay home with the baby the
baby's sick
my heart is breaking and i have tears
running down my face and i'm gonna stay
home with my baby my baby is sick we cut
our income in half you can't ignore the
fact that you have to also cut your
expenses in half simultaneously and you
didn't do that right
the first part you did was heroic the
second part you did was stupid
sell your house
okay
for your child for your child sell your
house
right you can't afford your house on
your husband's income
am i right
yes okay
all right
the house is a um
it is a collateral damage
to the situation with your child and
what you're declaring when you do this
is that you spending time and being
there for this sick baby is more
important than the stupid house
exactly
because you cannot live in a fantasy
mathematically
you don't get a pass on math
because you're a hero for a sick baby
you should be a hero for a sick baby
you're an amazing woman he's an amazing
guy you got a hard tough situation i'm
sorry you're facing this but do not make
it worse
my concern is right now um
our debt to income
even if we sold our home i'm
i guess to sell to purchase another home
i mean we would have
a decent we have a decent amount of
equity what is your what is your what is
your house payment
um our house payment is a little over
100. and what is his take on pay
um
his base take home a month is only 1800
but he makes commission on top of that
and it very great what does he make a
month right now um
his take home is 1800.
he's not making anything above the 1800
a month
right now he is um
last month let me see
um
last month he brought home three
thousand you cannot you cannot have an
eleven hundred dollar house payment with
three thousand dollar income money
right
it doesn't work
doesn't work
something has to change and here's the
thing something's going to change
you're either going to change it or
somebody's going to change it for you
called a foreclosure
and a bankruptcy
because you're you're driving a car
straight at the wall mathematically
aren't you
yeah
you you you are in denial about the fact
that the math sucks with the fact that
the baby being sick is sucks
yes
and the mat it causes the math to suck
and you can't you gotta face the whole
thing
it's your best way through this
your best way to win long term is to
face the whole thing and what's going to
happen i can tell you i'm i'll just be a
prophet are you ready
five years from today this is the five
years from today
the seizures will be gone
he's gonna be a normal little boy
running around like crazy and you're
gonna be back teaching and this is all
gonna be in your rear view mirror but
it's gonna be in your rear view mirror
faster if you deal with the present
full reality today
okay
crystal you said earlier that the reason
you came home from the classroom was for
your emotional well-being
and yet all of this debt
is causing just as much emotional stress
so you've got to implore your husband to
understand that we made this decision
for my emotional and mental well-being
and yet i'm not getting the benefits of
that because of our finances and this is
a season and you don't need to be
thinking about a house you sell the
house
and you rent and this is a circle the
wagons moment for your family where we
circle the wagons and we defeat the
enemy in front of us and then
you're going to get another home
explorer
you're not going to get one on three
thousand dollars a month yeah
right and you're not going to get one in
this current situation whoopty dumpty
there's another house i've been to
cleveland ohio there's houses all over
the place you can get you another house
right
they're everywhere yeah so you'll get
you another one yeah this is this is a
moment in time this is what's known as
the valley
you are in the valley right
but the point of value is you don't stay
there you're not going to live your
whole life in the valley it doesn't turn
it doesn't work out that way
and so this is the thing you'll look
back on and you'll tell you know you'll
tell your little boy's kids someday you
know when your kid your daddy was one he
about drove us nuts we had to sell the
house oh you know
you're gonna be there you'll be that
grandmother telling that story right
that's what's gonna happen crystal i can
tell you how many times my mom and dad
have talked about when i came into this
world they live in this teeny tiny one
bedroom see now there's a
well imagine trying to parent me for
heaven's sakes but you know this is a
season and i don't remember it your
son's not going to remember it
and and this is a storm
this is a storm right now and
i got to tell you it's not for your
emotional well-being you're being a good
mom that's right a good mom wants to be
there with a one-year-old that's having
seizures
that's just a good mom yeah i mean
that's not a bad thing thank you and if
if you were my own kid i would tell you
to do exactly what you're doing except
for the part where you kept all the
expenses
right
so those got to go starting today and
then you'll come back out of this and
you'll be able to add a house back and
you'll be able to now the last thing of
this is i want to ask you this
how available with this medical
situation are you
to do tutoring in your own
home um we've talked about that even um
for this next upcoming school year like
40 an hour schedule
yeah make a huge difference if you can
if you have the bandwidth and it doesn't
put your child in jeopardy
right i'm not trying to have you quit
working trying to put you back to work
that wasn't what i was trying to do but
i am but if there's some bandwidth while
kiddo is sleeping or kiddo is manageable
99 of the time but we're just here to
watch him
and make sure he's not having an episode
right then then you can do some 40 an
hour
uh tutoring and you can change this
whole situation and maybe keep the house
yeah i would tell you a very specific
idea there dave is online teaching adult
education makes really good money and
the little guy's in sleep she's got the
mom you're in control of when you do it
yeah yeah
online online tutoring big time help
yeah check on all that but kiddo make
the adjustments on the out go when you
make the adjustments on the income
that's what i want you to do so you win
in this you call us anytime we'll be
honored to help